Speaker 1: We have new swing state polling.
And I want to be really clear about this. This
is general election swing state polling, which
finds that Ron DeSantis would do better against
Joe Biden than would Donald Trump. This does not
mean the Republican maggots are going to choose
someone other than Trump to be their nominee.
This doesn't mean any of that. Trump is still
the most likely Republican nominee. It just means
that Trump's claim that he would beat Biden where
DeSantis would lose is not borne out by the facts.
Why do we care about swing states? We care about
swing states because whether it's the Santos or
Trump, Joe Biden, Biden's going to win California,
whether it's the Santos or Trump. DeSantis or
Trump are going to win Wyoming. The election is
going to come down to a group of swing states in
those swing states. We are increasingly getting
data that Ron DeSantis would do better against
Joe Biden than would Donald Trump. I'm not giving
advice to Republicans. I'm just telling you
this is what the data shows. If you look at a
new poll out of Pennsylvania, you find that Biden
leads Trump, but DeSantis leads Biden. Remember,
these are hypothetical matchups where you
say to people, if it were Trump versus Biden,
who do you vote for? If it were Desanctis versus
Biden, who do you vote for? And people respond.
In Georgia, an important state that Joe Biden
won in 2020. Unusually so for Democrats in recent
years. In Georgia, Biden leads Trump,
But DeSantis leads Biden. In Arizona,
another really important state. Biden leads
Trump. But this. Santos leads Biden. Let's
see what else we have from swing states. That may
be it for recent ones. Oh, Michigan. In Michigan,
Biden and Trump are tied. DeSantis leads
by a very small margin, statistically,
probably a dead heat. So the important takeaway
here is that the Republican electorate right now,
it's June 27th, right? This could change. Trump
gets arrested a third or fourth time. DeSantis
comes up with some free pony plan that everybody
loves. All of a sudden are free zebras. Who knows?
It could change. The point right now is in these
very important contested states, swing states,
DeSantis is polling better than Trump against
the most likely Democratic nominee, Joe Biden.
So it might be the logical thing for Republicans
to select someone with a better shot at winning,
but they seem determined to select Donald Trump.